es war einmal ein kleiner glücklicher
junge doch er hatte einen zeit und es
geschah dass sie aufeinander trafen
[Musik]
hier gaben sein zimmer mit ihm gehalten
haben das schon gesehen und deswegen
haben wir bei unserem
[Musik]
richtig schwierig
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich habe die bahn keine improvisation
sondern wir haben schon länger gehabt
habe mit entscheidungen gefüllt wird du
noch gegen die wegwerfen und dann rein
[Musik]
euro aufgestockt
kleiner für den von allen relevanten
nicht getroffen
wirklich so einfach
[Musik]
wenn ihr das video gefeiert dann können
wir hier unten abonnieren oder hier oben
das letzte video anschauen